so a while back I had Xavier on the
podcast and we talked about the junto
group or the mastermind group that we
were in and me and you that's how we met
that or so that's how we got to know
each other was being in a mastermind
together and I'll start with a book club
and so I just mentioned this on the
podcast and I think I've had over 400
people and said hey if you're interested
I can I have a playbook on how we run it
like you know how we recruit people how
we run the thing blah blah and 400
people have messaged me saying I'd like
that playbook and so they're on this
list of people and one of the things
that came out of it was people really
want to be in the CEO groups and these
exist I think this stage is one that's
popular they charge a bunch of money
eighteen grand yeah eighteen million
dollar your business crazy but like to
me those feel like dinosaurs I
remember when Vistage first called me
and I was like this is a scam
like do not call me for this and like I
know people get value out of it but the
amount you're charging for something
that is like a very basic service seemed
very odd to me so I actually want to do
this out of the community of people who
listen to this podcast who want to have
you want to be in CEO groups I don't
know if it's digital or we find you
people in your cities because there's
enough people who listen to this where
we can create groups of eight in cities
so if somebody wants to like take this
idea and run with it I don't have the
time but I think we can create a
business doing that well and so this is
what we're doing with trends which is
don't charge eighteen grand its trends
is three hundred dollars a year and we
have a group and we found that group to
be the most valuable valuable thing for
people so if you want like a little
taste of this sign up for trends but
then we're considering the same thing
which is how do we have a higher end
thing which self-selects a little bit
more right so yeah I'm I'm super bullish
on these types of groups I feel like I
understand how they work now the hard
part is you got to really pick the right
angle yeah that's the hard part but
there is absolute need for this and I
think it's only gonna grow as digital
gets more popular right
yeah digital detox is like the trend
that that but you know all these nature
base programs we talked about fall into
[Music]